what's up guys it's Charlie this is
going to be my Walking Dead episode 15
video we are at the finale so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet there's a new round of
the walking dead giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so it's finally
coming together I feel like they did a
good job of telegraphing everything
earlier this season but this episode of
Walking Dead beat you in the face with
the stuff that it's going to be doing
next week with the big twist the big
character arcs especially Gregory in the
Savior's like they really want you to be
ok with things taking a dramatic turn as
negan says there are big plans so let's
do top 10 WTF comic book Easter eggs
starting with number 10 Tara finally
tells the group about Oceanside I love
Rick's reaction what how dare you why
didn't you tell us before he's speaking
for the rest of the audience and I don't
know if any of you guys sympathized with
Parra she was trying to keep her word
like you want to feel like she's
honorable but the smart thing to do
would have been to tell them but for
most of the episode they did want to
make you wonder how things were going to
go down like would they actually come to
blows with someone end up getting killed
when they came to take the guns so I
loved the montage Walking Dead for all
of its faults it does a really good job
with the different intros way back
during season 5 season 6 they actually
had some of the best different intro
montages that the show has ever done so
this was pretty good I wouldn't say it's
one of the best ones but they did do a
really good job with the way they cut
Tara's voiceover with them marching to
Oceanside making their plans cutting it
with Carl's character acknowledging how
he does think about all the dead people
that he's killed so it's sort of like a
tee up for all the craziness that's
going to be happening next week in
trying to make you feel the weight of it
like there's going to be consequences
they have to do what needs to be done we
are all really hyped up for a battle
royale but I think they're using Carl's
character just to try to make you feel
like lives matter the Savior's that are
going to end up dying their lives
mattered even if some of them were
terrible people the survivors are going
to die too I think about the people that
I didn't kill so in that way Carl's kind
of like the conscience of the group like
yeah this is going to suck we're going
to kill a lot of people even though we
as the audience are like hell yeah kill
as many people as you want to they do a
pretty good job
setting up the Sascha twist with Jesus's
character I'm a little worried about him
and Daryl's like she can take care of
herself they're probably back at Hilltop
by now already so of course big twist
number nine they open the cell door and
it's sasha sitting in there she's
captive of the Savior's and they keep
talking about the fracas as negan calls
it that she caused last night makes it
sound like she killed a bunch of people
before they took her down but you guys
can let me know how you felt about that
twist like they definitely left a lot of
action off the page so your mind is just
left to wonder like how crazy was this
like sometimes it's cool when they do
that but it's hard to tell if they left
that action off the page because they
just wanted to move the plot along or
because they wanted to save money for
big action set piece in the finale so I
think we're in agreement that it would
have been cool to get at least a few
quick cuts of a montage when negan
referred to the fracas or when David was
talking about last night before he got
all creepy on her but I love the negan
twist when he is like not cool man you
broke my one rule we do not take
advantage of women in that way and just
stab him right in the throat is actually
a pretty cool pretty subtle effect so
now the big surprise is trying to get
her to turn but she's such a badass that
you know she's not going to turn until
number eight Eugene walks in and you
really know she's not going to turn like
she used has hate in her eyes for him I
love that reaction like she's holding it
all back inside of her like the more
quiet she gets the more you're just
waiting for her to jump out like they
both remember Abraham and he starts to
justify what he did I don't ever want to
feel as afraid as I did that night that
Glenn and Abraham died when he's talking
about that moment that he never wants to
go back to the reason he joined the
Savior's is that so he would never be
forced into that situation again he's
talking about the season premiere so for
about 30 minutes of his life he felt
very brave and then it all went to crap
in this moment right here I thought my
number was up so in that moment I was
totally okay with her taking him down
like Eugene was a nice character he has
a lot of his own charm there might still
be a chance for him to redeem himself
but I feel like this is them trying to
make you feel okay if he does die in the
finale so you guys can let me know do
you actually want Eugene to make it to
Season eight but speaking of people
making it to season eight number seven
Maggie
shows everyone including us the audience
what a coward Gregory is never before
has a storyline been telegraphed so much
like they really want you to think that
Maggie is going to be this amazing
leader she's a pregnant single mother
who knows how to farm has all these
skills but they've been setting this up
all the way since season six when she
started working with Deanna learning how
to be an administrator of a big
community that was the whole part of her
arc with deanna deanna kind of teaching
her how to start being a leader in
england that sort of forcing her on her
own hero's journey so there was ever a
character that you could lay a bet on
hundred percent not going to die gonna
make it to season eight maggie would be
it so they just want a foreshadow that
she will take over hilltop and she will
be a good leader that everyone likes and
will be totally cool with Gregory not
being in charge anymore
that was why they included that scene of
the group walking by as Gregory was
throwing up after she killed the Walker
that was on top of him like he told us
that he was totally badass at killing
walkers so you have to imagine that
everybody would freak out if you killed
the leader of a group but they want you
to feel really okay if Gregory suddenly
isn't the leader anymore like oh yeah he
was a douchebag anyway so we're totally
cool with somebody else being a leader
somebody like Maggie maybe for number
six the survivors roll in to Oceanside
dropping bombs so the big thing here is
they don't want to demonize them because
they need to take the weapons and they
just want you to wonder like the whole
attention was is would someone die and
stand off the side like they really want
you to believe in the survivors and
Rick's group going forward so they're
going to do everything they can to make
you feel like their actions are
justified no matter how terrible they
seem like they take a bunch of their
supplies do you need to take everything
yeah we need all this really the only
thing that surprised me in this
storyline is that more of the Oceanside
people didn't join the survivors I
figured that about half the group would
stay half the group would go like you
have Cindy who's like yeah we need to
fight them but it seems like she stayed
behind I did like the way that they've
brought back that Beach Roemer like the
big event that catalyzes the group that
sort of brings them together is the
walker attack and you see the walker
from the beginning of the episode who is
on the beach but they got the guns now
they can get down to business the
important thing though that they did not
follow up on they're still sort of a
hanging
here is that Heath is still missing and
there's the key card the PPP card which
i think is the way that they get into
one of the satellite stations I guess we
have to assume they're going to follow
up on that in the finale but number four
Sacha convinces negan and Eugene that
she's turned so the big thing here you
know totally telegraphing the fact that
she's just trying to cozy up to negan so
she get another chance to kill him but
she has to prove herself as negan says
in turn on Rick tell me what they're up
to because I have something big planned
for tomorrow so he's talking about the
finale he has big plans just like Rick
has big plans so they're just hyping up
big Battle Royale the real fun of this
moment because you totally know what
action she's going to take her
motivation her character is pretty clear
what she wants to do so the fun of this
moment is just her trying to convince
Eugene to bring her a weapon just like
before 100% okay with her taking Eugene
down if she needs to but the big twist
of that you know number three is that he
brings her back to the pill that he made
for the wives remember he was like I
can't in my good conscience help you
kill someone else but now he's like okay
I'm totally okay with you killing
yourself you seem like a good person but
really I feel like it's just the show's
way of letting you know that he is
almost too far gone like in the way that
Dwight has turned Eugene has also been
poisoned by his fear so it's like okay
he does not deserve to go on there's
still might be a chance for him if he's
inspired so what they might do is if he
does die in the finale is this they'll
just give him some heroic way to go out
like okay one final moment to be brave
and sacrificed himself for everyone else
but I feel like after all of his
speeches in this episode that is the
only way to redeem the character number
two coward Gregory sort of the
juxtaposition of Sasha when negan's like
you need to tell me what Rick's up to he
pulls out the bottle of whiskey that he
was talking about with Simon and starts
looking at a map just letting you know
that he is probably going to go talk to
Simon have that glass of whiskey with
him and totally rat out what the
survivors are trying to do he makes it
sound like their trip is going to be an
overnight thing so I know it seems like
they're setting up an awful lot of plot
that they have to get through in
addition to whatever big final battle
goes down but they did say that the
finale is going to be super-sized it'll
be extra long I don't know
how much longer maybe like an extra half
hour on top of a normal episode but
number one they roll up to the safe zone
and Rosita's like I got a surprise for
you and it's Dwight
so it was Dwight at the end of the last
episode he has turned and is ready to
help them fight the Savior's so if you
have read the comic book please use
spoiler tags if you want to talk about
it because they're being very faithful
to some characters storylines from the
comics and I know a lot of you are
wondering if they're going to give Sasha
as a Halle twist so there's a lot of
questions about her character because
she's going to be on another TV show
later this year so it's like is she
gonna film that between seasons of
Walking Dead are they going to kill her
off because it seems like she's been
marked for death like she has the pill
and there's no way I think she's going
to kill herself but she already implied
heavily to Rosita that she was
sacrificing herself for the group you
have to go on they need you there has to
be a reason for all this so in my mind
the minute that Sasha did that she was
dead it's just that she has a couple
really cool things that she's going to
do before she dies like kill a whole
bunch of saviors so let me know in the
comments who do you think is going to
die in the finale of the survivors
I feel like negan is not going to die
he'll make it to Season eight he's too
big of a character but I think of the
survivors that Sasha in Eugene OR at the
top of my death list and definitely
Sasha is at the top I think Eugene
there's a strong chance that he could
also die to let me know all the death
predictions in the comments what's going
to happen next is is there's new Game of
Thrones there's going to be a new
spider-man trailer really soon so I'll
try to get through all the Marvel's DC
stuff folks say congratulations to the
latest walking dead giveaway winner
third ray please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round in this video announce the winner
when I post my finale video where you
wait for that click here for a new
spider-man all the craziness from
Justice League the last couple days and
you can click here for all my Walking
Dead videos thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video
you